many call adam ray the king of crowdwork
for one reason i recently posted an ian
bag clip of him turning a single word
into an entire bit and adam ray can do
the same by simply
listening but in this clip adam is able
to turn something not cool into
hilarious smoke a lot of pot up there
bud
doesn't sound like it's affected your
brain at all
[Applause]
and just by listening he's able to drag
out a single stoned word into an entire
bit what's your name dude
yeah you forgot see how high
this guy is
if that's not a commercial for don't
smoke weed kids
what's your name here to think about uh
well give me a second dude what's the
pop quiz shout out to my buddy tamua for
requesting this adam ray breakdown as it
shows exactly why